willkommen zurück tag nummer hier und
heute starten wir mit einer skin care
team weil ich in dem blog gestern
ich konnte es mir nicht anschauen bzw
musste ich mir gerade anschauen weil ich
wieder mal fünf stunden an diesem video
geschnitten habe und ich sage mir immer
am anfang macht nicht zu krass mach
einfach ein paar schnitte rein damit es
nicht allzu lang ist aber ich mache dann
doch immer noch ein sound effekt und
hier und da und das überhaupt ja dass
ich jetzt von 7 uhr bis 13 uhr
geschnitten habe sechs stunden also okay
ich hab da zwischendurch mal ein kamin
unser war sechs stunden ich habe keine
ahnung wie ich meine make-up routine
gefallen hat und deswegen zeige ich euch
jetzt auch noch mal eine skin care ihn
kriegen anruf gewartet
[Musik]
ich muss einer gehen werde ich sagen
denn von so was sagen sie das einhalten
und dann auch nach glasers durch
das durchziehen und dann ob ich dann für
meine morgendliche skin care team nehme
ich den locate good morning sagt lenders
und weil im monat dezember für mich
achtsamkeit ganz groß geschrieben wird
massiere ich die scheiße ganz sorgfältig
rein und mit einem mikrofaser handtuch
seid ihr ganz nett sein gesicht damit
ihr dann mit dem schocker strawberry
extra aging facemash eure ganzen toten
hautschuppen mit diesem gel schön
abrubbeln könnt und wenn ich abrubbeln
meine dann meine ich richtig rein reiben
alles was der tod noch drauf liegt und
was das make-up scheiße aussehen lässt
muss runter und nochmal gently mit dem
mikrofaser handtuch abtrocknen und mit
der lift losheimer lifting augen
korrektur kann ich meine augen strafen
und der anti müdigkeit effekt sehe ich
gar nicht aber irgendwie fühlt sich gut
an das zu benutzen hier möchte ich
wirklich nicht sagen wie dieses produkt
heiß weil ich alles falsch aussprechen
würde
[Musik]
ach so stimmt können sie gar nicht meine
blogs schauen 19 minuten ganz so ja ich
habe über eine stunde gebraucht um den
durchzug o aber du bist dran geblieben
mit der schon sagen und so das hat spaß
gemacht
ja das weil du guckst mehr und da freue
ich mich eigentlich war ein netter
lustiger zu sehen und so hat es gut
gemacht
gestern haben sie gegessen weiß ich
nicht bekommen wir meine mutter channel
[Musik]
okidoki hier sehen sie das exemplar
halloumi burger mit tomate und salat
lecker wasserkontakt immer ein fremdwort
ist
[Musik]
und danach gehen wir den weihnachtsbaum
holen aber wir gehen ihn an der
chausseestraße abholen also wir leihen
ihn aus ich glaube ich werde dieses jahr
den tannenbaum ausleihen weil den kamen
dann im neuen jahr wieder abgeben wo ich
weiß wir sind ja über weihnachten
minister wenn wir über weihnachten ist
da sind
den muss man ja gießen wenn du leben ist
schon da konnte er seinem job nicht dann
gibt es wieder ab und an
ja ja die haben sogar um die ecke welche
wenn sich leute beschweren warum du so
was sagt so einfach es war diese
wirklich dazu gezwungen tipps für mich
so richtig
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich ein meeting an meinem
esszimmertisch wie also wir machen einen
wir machen ein
eine story genauso mehr als ersten habe
ich jetzt gesagt viel genau
da kannst du mir schicken ich habe
meinen laptop auf
[Musik]
warum mache ich mir nach dem essen nicht
den mund auf
[Musik]
kann mal gucken also wenn wir sofort ja
sagen dann können wir uns wieder ärgern
dass wir nicht noch höher gegangen sind
[Musik]
was cool wäre ich habe eine idee ich
habe eine idee was wird denn auch
gefallen weil es ist gerade so ein
bisschen auch auf tickt optionen trend
dass du schnitzt und dann zb dein zimmer
so aufgeräumt ist und du siehst quasi
sowie also als ob man so ein handy video
kann aufnehmen mein team muss er jetzt
bekannt so den können wir jetzt ja dafür
benutzen
[Musik]
wisst ihr was ich manchmal youtube hasse
ich wollte gerade raus gehen und paket
abzuholen
und dann habe ich mir ein video
angeschaut weil ich nur kurz auf die app
geben wollte ich war nur kurz mal kappen
heister neumann habe ich so ein video
über bulimie und anorexie gesehen ich
habe das gefühl dass erst seit ich meine
panikattacken hat kann ich so verstehen
durch was für ein struggle so leute
gehen die hand
ja nicht gesund sind und ich wünsche
eben da draußen wirklich vom ganzen
herzen dass man hier gerade mit
irgendwas arbeiten müsste oder irgendwas
verarbeiten müsst oder durch eine
schwere zeit geht das ich hoffe du mich
sonst nicht besser geht weil
es ist so wichtig gesund zu bleiben das
ist so wichtig offenen aufzupassen
bitte vergesst das nicht so komisch weil
man jetzt einfach alles mitnimmt
und manchmal habe ich das gefühl wenn
man irgendwann schaut und traurig findet
und dann hält man so alles zurück aber
das ist halt nicht gut irgendwas
zurückzuhalten wenn du dich traurig filz
und die absetzung weinen muss dann
bringt es nichts zu sagen dass man nicht
weinen sollte was quatsch ich muss ein
paket abholen und das paket was ich
abholen muss ist glaube ich das
allerschönste was ich dieses jahr
bekommen werde
vermieter so lange drauf gefreut und
jetzt für den nicht nur welchen
trauriges video gesehen habe das war
nicht mal traurig dass gehen darum dass
sie es geschafft hat und aber immer noch
streiten muss und genau das will ich
halt ich habe es auch geschafft ich habe
keine panikattacken mir aber trotzdem
muss ich mich immer daran wieder
erinnern
der stress zu vermeiden und dinge zu tun
die man stress lösen
lasst uns erst mal unser drittes türen
aufmachen ich habe hier will diese wut
geraten welche paket ab auch weil den
tag super läuft dann kann eine sache
gekommen und dann muss man kurz traurig
sein
machen wir lieber unser päckchen nummer
3 auf für heute
[Musik]
und timo denkt er hat irgendwie
schlechteren kalender eheleute ich habe
mich mal so sachen wie er glaube ich
drin
ich habe lauter gutscheine und heute
muss ich auf jeden fall noch also ich
muss jetzt definitiv los weil ich muss
noch einige sachen für den bastel
großklub was hat er mir denn geholt
kleine äpfel zum basteln habe ich ihn
verdient das weiß ich nicht
und eine achtsamkeit karte haben wir
heute auch bewusste beobachtung der
natur die übung ist einfach und
gleichzeitig sehr wirksam
wer ein objekt der natur eine blume
einen sekt einen baum
es spielt keine rolle was es ist
entspanne dich jetzt und erforschen
dieses objekt als hättest du es noch
niemals zuvor gesehen er kunde wieso er
jeden aspekt trete in verbindung mit dem
objekt ein bisschen rolle in der natur
so lange es deine konzentration führe
diese übung heute mindestens zwei mal
durch naja ich bin ja gleich auf dem weg
schauen wir uns das noch ein baum an
auch das hat meine stimmung wieder
gehoben es ist aber auch verrückt
krieg ich irgendwie meine tage bald
geschieht manchmal gleich auf seine tage
das ist auch nicht in ordnung man ist ja
nicht nur traurig also man ist relativ
also ich bin relativ oft traue ich mir
meinen tage trotzdem ist das nicht die
entschuldigung für alles okay lass los
leute ich bin so aufgeregt in dem paket
und ich brauche es unbedingt für morgen
wenn es das ist ich bin mir nicht so zu
100 prozent sicher ist das ist aber es
könnte sein und deswegen
nicht so mit gewalt oder was ich will
gerade so erleichtert dass ich nicht
mitgekommen will und wird die schlange
ist mir dann immer wenn ich irgendwo in
der schlange stehe warten muss oder die
zeit vertreiben höre ich gerne ein
podcast und gerade bin ich bei
gemischtes hat hängen geblieben
irgendwann wenn ich einmal einen podcast
mache wird der schlange stehen heißen
und da wird sich darum drehen wie es ist
in einer schlange zu stehen oder der
bürger liegt mir so schwer im magen
was ich sagen wollte ich habe mein paket
noch nicht bekommt ich hab's schon
gesehen
ich durfte nicht mit karte zahlen
deswegen habe ich das jetzt noch nicht
bekommen
ich darf jetzt also ich will noch zu
rewe einkaufen habe ich gesagt da haben
die gesagt dass ich nach rewe halt noch
mal zurückkommen soll mit bargeld wenn
man bei rewe ja abheben kann
und ich muss sagen nach bin so genervt
von leuten die da hinkommen und sich nur
beschweren dass die schlange so lange
ist und dass die lange länger nach
paketen suchen müssen ich meine es ist
die vorweihnachtszeit ich hab eh schon
schlechtes gewissen dass mein paket weil
jemand anderem ankommen muss besonders
bei sonderpaket annahmestelle wieder
post ihre in diesem späten drin und dann
war vor mir suchen kannte co
ich dachte ich ich bin jetzt wieder zu
hause angekommen und habe mein paket
aber ich sage euch erst morgen was drin
ist denn morgen benutze ich das auch
gleich ja und ansonsten ich bin echt
schockiert darüber wie die leute an der
schlange bei der post da irgendwie sich
dauerhaft beschwert haben
es sind so viele leute immer weiter
reingekommen und es waren so viele
pakete bei dieser post abgabe das ist in
so einem späteren so und ich muss jetzt
noch die restlichen sachen einpacken für
den adventskalender von timo weil ja
ich habe ein bisschen gebraucht um mein
gott ich hab ich eh adventskalender
nicht aufgemacht sorry es wird natürlich
jetzt sofort nachgeholt was ist in
türchen nummer 33 schokolade schmeckt
die strecke schmeckt wie diese all die
schokolade diese weise mit christin
dieses bild so schön die behauptung wie
darin verliebt und jetzt sitze ich hier
in meinem zimmer was irgendwie mein
atelier geworden ist weil ich meinen
schreibtisch rüber geräumt habe es
stehen hier meine ganzen bilder
es ist so unordentlich hier ich war ich
wollte euch gerade zeigen
ich werde auch beim videodreh es wird
schon zwei nach köln
es ist viel los ist viel und und können
wir bitte über den ersten wochen ist
lockt von so eller reden die alde der
einen geht es nicht gut
als gefragt wo dieser blogs tech-blog
muss ich meine es ist ja wirklich queen
of rock mist ich verbinde locken ist nun
mit ihr und ihr geht einfach nicht so
gut und dann will sie es diesmal weniger
machen ich habe heute schon gemerkt dass
heute ist schon echt hart also nicht
hart aber ich war glaube ich ultra müde
einfach vor dem ganzen arbeiten
ich glaube letztes jahr war ich schon an
den punkt ab tag 3 dass ich gesagt habe
war gefragt bei dem es sich vorstellen
ein bis zwei videos die woche zu
produzieren und hochzuladen das ist für
mich so fulltime job weil wir haben ja
nicht nur das zu tun wir müssen ja auch
telefonate führen meetings haben wir
viel aber ich muss das ich sagen so oder
mich nicht erklären oder versuchen euch
zu vermitteln dass ich auch arbeite ich
arbeite
deswegen ist halt jeden tag ein video
hardcore na ja und ich wollte rewe und
habe noch süßigkeiten für kinos
adventskalender geholt weil ich das bis
jetzt noch nicht geschafft habe ich habe
alle anderen sachen also materielles
zeug dinge die man nicht essen kann
die sind alle schon dran drin hier ist
auch noch eins und süßigkeiten noch
gewählt
twitter warnung für timo ab jetzt darfst
du nicht mehr zuschauen
jetzt ist vorbei also was ich mir
überlegen habe für die süßigkeiten
ich hab gedacht ich möchte sagen dass
ich mir was cooles überlegt habe für die
süßigkeiten weil ich dachte an den tagen
an denen es was süßes gibt soll da auch
so ein kleiner touristen sein weil sonst
habe ich auch noch gutscheine und rätsel
mit so kleinen geschenken gemacht aber
für die süßigkeiten türen wollte ich
auch was cooles machen und zwar habe ich
süßigkeiten gekauft wie zum beispiel
jetzt hier die fünf bildschirm jetzt
aussieht wie eine 2 habe ich also
ich hab ne 5 gemacht auf jeden fall ist
es ist da knoppers mit fünf riegeln drin
und da steht das dann auch immer so groß
drauf zum beispiel sind hier sechs stück
drin und dann habe ich von den ready 2
stück gekauft und dann sind sie für
türchen 12 genau für türchen nummer 10
gibt es zehn hanuta stücke ich dachte
das ist eigentlich ganz cool und mein
lieblingsstück ist das hier die hat timo
am anfang so gehasst als ich sie mal
gezeigt habe aber ich kenne sie noch aus
polen also irgendwie haben wir sie da
ständig gegessen
und hier sind genau 22 stück drin also
ist als für küchen 22
[Musik]
bei diesem hier sind 26 stück drin aber
das schüsschen 23 also musste ich aus
jeder sorte ein rausnehmen ist eine
offene physische ganze ist wirklich zu
viel schokolade gerade nicht gut für
mein bauch tut schon weh
[Musik]
simons locken wirst du willst eine
kamera nie sicher schon bald ins bett
mit der kamera gespielt wenn du wirst
schon aus für meine abend routine
verwende ich gut und gerne mal das zeigt
hier dass bei dieser marke
monza ist dieses 6.30 uhr aufstehen
können mich gewöhnen aber das gute ist
das habe auch schickt man den ganzen tag
die sonne
diese habe ich mir new york geholt sind
auch von der gleichen firma des
verschnitt und kippte komplex erst mal
wird man dein gesicht mit sicht seite
und danach bin ich mal doch gerade bei
nike diese ewig lange liste an kaufte
pflegeprodukten gesehen die er da
verwendet
dann muss ich mir echt ne scheibe
abschneiden
es könnte sein dass diese creme meiner
stirn hilft in diesem alter angekommen
wo man sich um eincremen und so gedanken
machen muss
guck mal ich habe von aus england
richtig schöne seife mitgenommen dass
eine seife und die riecht so der
esoterisch nach mandarine klopp
instrument auf der base von cocoon
arterien
und dann es daneben noch eine gleiche
tube mit handcreme ich habe nie was
praktisches gesehen ich glaube ich muss
mich auch mal ganz eincremen heute
gesehen wie trocken meine beine sind
kennt ihr das bei seiner sahara wenn du
so diesen aufgerissenen bohn hat genau
so seemann trailer zu god i benutze ich
den charity pot von lush einerseits die
beste bis jetzt benutzt habe und
andererseits wird das halt komplett
gespendet
oh mein gott wie sie meine beine haus
liegt es nur an kalten wetters kann mir
gar nicht stellen
okay erinnert mich bitte in den
kommentaren immer wieder vanessa kriegen
wir deine beine ein häufigkeit letzte
chat lebensunfähig die haut kann nicht
besser aussehen ist okay bei aller
menschen und damit heißt mensch warst du
lust den block noch mit mir zu beenden
ich habe einfach noch kein auto gemacht
deswegen muss ich das jetzt aus dem bett
machen
ich möchte sagen es war mir heute wieder
ein fest mit ihnen den tag verbracht zu
haben
ich hoffe ich konnte ihnen den ein oder
anderen schmunzler rausholen morgen
backen wir vielleicht kekse was sagst du
auf jeden fall na ja gut dann gute nacht
leuten wieder eingeben
[Musik]
warum beziehen so ein schönes licht nun
länger bleiben
gut jetzt genau warum soll ich gute
nacht und ob sie gleich schlafen gehen
müssen
geht mal schlafen gute nacht